hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting game from the 2019 ulti box
Norway championship it's again between
Dingley rand and wesley so and their
classical game ended in a draw so we're
not going to be showing that one as I
still haven't decided if I was showing
both games both classical and the
Armageddon one or just your macaron one
but for now until I decide otherwise
we're just gonna be sticking with with
either one of them or maybe in some rare
case where maybe I will show both of
them in the same video but not on this
one so like I said they drew the
classical game and now as ding had
acquired the white piece in the in the
classical event he also now gets the
white pieces in Armageddon so ten
minutes for doing seven minutes for
Wesley and ding has to win the game so
let's see what happened in the game
ding opened with C for the English
opening with East six and now Knight to
c3 I with d5 by Wesley and now d4 and
here Knight to f6 so a bit of a
different order of moves but we are
again in the in the Queens gambit
declined so here we have seek a person
d5 ding goes for the early capture nice
captors on d5 and now efore Knight
captures and c3b captures on c3 and now
c5 just attacking a nice flank attack
against the white strong center and here
looked a b1
I always useful move yeah black probably
will not be developing the bishop via g6
and Bishop to g7 that way we would well
pretty much transposing into the groom
field but rather Bishop to e7 will be
played but the rook is already nicely
placed here on the semi open B file with
Knight to f3 biding preparing to develop
the bishop and also castle
we have castles by Wesley and here it's
interesting that Wesley so already
played this position he played it
against Carson in Abidjan in the code
the war this year we already covered
that game it was in the rapids where
Coulson one and in that game Carson went
to Bishop to e2 but dinga doesn't
doesn't play this line and of course
Wesley most likely improved on that line
so he goes Bishop to c4 but it's
interesting ding already had this
position against
Vladimir Kramnik but we're gonna get to
that very soon
so the Bishop e2 the move crossed and
played a Wesley replied would be six but
here he goes a six and he's preparing b5
to push back the bishop so doing
prevents it we have a four and now Queen
to c7 preparing to capture and from then
the Queen will be attacking the bishop
on c4 and as I already mentioned I think
had this position in 2017 in Antalya
against Vladimir Kramnik where he played
Bishop to d3 so he retreated this way
but now he goes Bishop to e2 the game
against chronic ended in a draw so
Bishop to e2 a different line maybe
Wesley does not know this one and here
there this position has been reached
before for example in Croatian
championship 2018 social Martina which
had this position against anti shortage
where C capture son before was played
that game ended in a draw but here we
have b6 by Wesley preparing to
fianchetto the light-square bishop and
as of this moment has a movie 11 we have
a completely new game sorry if I sneeze
now and then I seem to have caught
something I don't know because it was
raining in Croatia for like the past 30
days and now it's a very sunny like for
the past few days and now you know I I'm
starting to feel it so sorry about that
with castles by dink and now comes C
capture Sundy for C capture some before
end Bishop to b7 so I think entering the
light square bishop while attacking this
guy here and now butter up to d3 so a
lot of moves with the bishop with a
light square bishop for ding but at some
point d5 or e5 will be played and this
Bishop definitely belongs
undie 3 to control this very important
diagonal we have knife the c6 Wesley it
starts developing pieces and now rook to
b3 sorry about that I have prepared some
water in case this happens
[Music]
rook to b3 a very nice rook lift from
there after there should be one and
let's see if this Knight moves the rook
can now come in to g3 or even h3 to
start an attack against the black king
so a very nice relieved by ding but
Wesley media to react
and pushes it back with Knight to a5
rook the b2 and now Knight back to c6
just you know he has the black pieces
it's Armageddon all Wesley needs is a
draw so Dean has to figure out another
way how to go about this we have looked
to d2 by dink and now comes look F to d8
Bishop to b2 now now both bishops are
nicely placed on this diagonal and we
have rook a to c8 here going for this
well last last work that needs to be
developed and here Dean says okay now
it's time to open up the bishop pair he
pushes d5 and before capturing what's
the first goes night to be four it's a
very useful move it opens up this Queen
rook battery to control the C file also
from there it pressures the light-square
bishop and also controls the d5 square
one more time and now the knight and the
ship are also defending it so here
bishop to be one thing of course is not
interested in giving giving the bishop
pair and now e captures on d5 but now
not recapturing but rather be five and
now the bishop comes alive and at some
point being is definitely threatening
even east six which would of course
freed the dark square bishop as well so
what do you do here if black plays a
slow move let's say something like a
five then e six immediately comes and
after F characters Knight goes to d4
hoping to jump over here and is just a
very unpleasant position for for black
to play so g6 by Wesley you know numbing
the power of this Bishop on b1 and we
have looked a 1 biding with D for
blocking the dark square bishop also
freeing up the light square bishop on b7
and finally we have a 6 from dink so
what do you do here Wesley doesn't like
capturing so he goes f6 now is this one
of those cases where it's actually okay
to play f6 well there's only one way to
find out and that is to continue
watching Knight captures on d4 by dink
now nicely placed knight guards this
pawn here and it's really a critical
position here
Wesley should definitely go Queen to f4
just you know nicely bringing the Queen
in to the game and if you push it back
Queen to h6 and the Queen
very nicely be defending the King said
but also here Wesley would already have
some threats like finish treat the Queen
to G - checkmate as the bishop is like
we mentioned nicely fin Carroll on b7
but instead after Knight captures on d4
Wesley won back Knight to c6 he wants to
trade on d4 but it simply doesn't work
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find best the best idea for white in
this position while I have a nice sip of
my water for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you were an
excellent maneuver of the night and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is Knight to f5 and it's a
really sneaky idea especially for a
blitz game how how doing spots it well
ok it's technically not a blitz game
it's a 10 versus 7 but I wouldn't really
call it a rapid either so let's just
call it an Armageddon the idea is very
nice because if the knight is captured
then Queen to h5 should will win you the
game at some point it's impossible to
say how far didn't calculated it but you
know there are a lot of sneaky lines for
example Knight e5 blocking the dark
square Bishop trying to bring the knight
over to help out bushel captures you
will give up the dark square Bishop F
captures and now rook to d7 is deadly
and you don't really have a good move if
you move the Queen then you lose the
bishop if you don't move the Queen if
you capture then the first Queen to f7
check and after King to a trait not
Bishop captures on f5 and now you can
see that there is very little you can do
to defend against checkmate you have to
play Bishop to f8 not the rook controls
the h7 square but now e capture Sun b7
and again the Queen no longer can help
out Queen captures on h7 is next here
you would have to play Queen captures
just give up the Queen and after Queen
captures again you're threatening
checkmate you'd have to go here but then
you know severe loss of material will
occur and it's just over for black so
Knight a5 beautiful move by ding Wesley
does not of course capture it he plays
rook caps or some d2 but now first
Knight captures on e7 eliminating a very
important defender here and now f6 will
no longer be guarded by such a nice dark
square Bishop we have queen cap
97 knockoffs Queen captures on b2 and
now King to g7 you have to help out with
the defense of the f6 pawn and now Queen
to f4 now being is about to pile up on
the f6 pawn we have rooked f8 defending
the f6 pawn and now h4 starting to bust
open the Kings side with Bishop to c8
now but ding just ignores it with h5 I'm
going after the black King and now
Knight to e5 and here of course you do
not want to win a pawn by playing Bishop
captures but rather rook captures as
this diagonal is simply much too
important with F captures and now comes
Queen captures on e5 with check and now
you don't really have all that many
squares here if you go team g8 Queen h8
is checkmate
the point is controlling the f7 Square
on the other hand if you play rook to f6
just blocking then you capture and after
H captures on g6 you will play Queen to
g5 the you will be enjoying this pin
very much because whatever black place
you are capturing and g6 would check you
cannot capture due to the pin after the
King moves then comes the Bishop
captures on f6 and you will be done
material but also you're just dead lost
here with black so after Queen captures
on e5 would check King to h6 was played
but here at ding just continues the
onslaught we have H capture some g 6h
captures and now of course it's a forced
checkmate so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this very nice
meeting sequence would best defense It's
Made in six but you know if you can do
better
feel free to try I'll give you a couple
of seconds while I have the last sip of
my water for those who were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
major in six and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show Queen to H
do check and now you don't really have
all that much to do kink the g5 was
played and here after Queen to g3 check
it was in this position that was we saw
resigned the game he resigned because
well whatever you do if King h6 then
this is mate in one
just Queen captures and g6 but we of
course want to see the best defense and
that is of course well you just have to
move or taking h5 so now if Queen
captures on g6 you can move which is
what will happen Queen captures here
King cast
Conn's g3 kink the h3 and now just
Bishop to f5 check you can capture with
the rook and now Queen captures on f5
it's checkmate and it's just uh just a
beautiful position our beautiful
checkmate but also your hell you could
also done Queen to h5 or even Queen to
f5 check this is even nicer you know if
you have an option of sacrificing your
Queen you should always do it as it is a
much cooler so a nice Bishop mate at the
point of course prevents the King from
reaching gauge for and the King covers D
square so it's all very nice yeah
an excellent victory for King ding and
probably we're gonna show one more game
so we're going to talk about the
standings then but yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Vasily
care of Rasmussen stefan schmidt crystal
Kieffer and the Daleks are gone for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and I would once
again like to thank everyone for you
know all of your updates on the other
matter of chess clock really so many so
many nice ideas and we hope to implement
them all well very soon and but I will
keep you posted
yeah I think I'll I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day